the la rams made it to the super bowl
last year what are they gonna do this
year we talked earlier about what the
expectations for this team should be
it's kind of vague right now i don't
expect another super bowl appearance not
many teams that lose the super bowl get
back the patriots the first team to lose
and get back and win it since the
dolphins in the early 70s and there were
real questions about the rams not the
same level of star power infusion that
we saw a year ago but still clay
matthews who knows how much he has left
eric weddle all due respect who knows
how much he has left either those are
the biggest names that they've added via
free agency guys who weren't with the
teams and then there's blake bortles
and what what grandma always say if you
can't say something nice about somebody
don't say anything at all so let's just
move on yeah uh
they're without some guys they had last
year and dominican su i think will be
signing with you know someone not the
rams i wouldn't be surprised if he ends
up in seattle that'd be a great way for
the seahawks to stick it to the rams a
little bit but i just you know look i
don't know where what the feel about
these rams i don't know how to feel
about jared goff i don't know how to
feel about todd gurley and that
arthritic knee that only got worse as
the year unfolded chris yeah i think
there's a lot of questions there
certainly i mean and you talked about
you know the last few years we've seen
talent infusion every year with the rams
whether it was sammy watkins you know
marcus peters and dama consu last year
the brandon cooks thing all of that hey
i do think eric weddle was a nice
signing they needed that position needed
a kind of some veteran stability back
there losing lamarcus joyner um but yeah
not that great splash that we've seen
but this team is pretty well set up now
the big thing is there's not a lot of
great depth on the football team that's
the one thing i look at with the rams
the last two years they've been very
fortunate to avoid the injury bug
because i do think them compared to
other teams i evaluate uh they would be
more susceptible to being in big trouble
if they got the injury bug as compared
to maybe other teams the other thing is
and you mentioned i mean sean mcvay
gonna have to reinvent himself a little
bit this year you know two years
of kind of being the king of offense in
the nfl or certainly one of the kings
and then towards the last year we saw a
few teams kind of crack the code down
the stretch uh to where yeah i think
he's going to have to find new wrinkles
and new schemes and new additions to the
offense uh to give jared goff and the
offense some advantages that way but how
long is the shelf life of this team
right mike i think that's the big thing
you know i i you know is this is this
one more year and we turn this over is
it two more years how does it go they
got some aging guys in a lot of
positions as you look across the roster
and go they only got a year or two left
before they got to start thinking of
replacements
yeah andrew whitworth almost didn't come
back at left tackle and jared goff's got
two years left on his rookie contract i
don't think it's a foregone conclusion
that he will be with that team over the
long haul i thought it was funny a
couple of weeks ago when the rams picked
up his fifth year option a lot of rams
fans crowed well this means that goff is
the guy i know it doesn't it hardly
means he's the guy
all it means is they're exercising their
option to keep them around for one more
year and then they're going to figure
out what they're going to do after that
they may not keep him around sean mcvay
may want to pick his own quarterback and
todd gurley is the thing that hovers
over all of this for me because they
made todd gurley
at the time the highest paid running
back in football with the long-term deal
with a ton of injury guarantee and then
the knee started to be a problem and
what can he really do and they used a
high pick on daryl henderson five foot
eight inch running back out of memphis a
guy with a rocket up his butt as you
would say a guy who can do a lot of
things in that offense and you know if
if todd gurley was getting a little
salty about cj anderson last year he's
going to get real salty about daryl
henderson because i don't think sean
mcveigh drafts that guy so high if he
doesn't plan to use him right away chris
well i i and even to your point even
further which i agree with you right
you're right i mean henderson's going to
be a part of this offense he's special
too i mean he can really make some big
time plays you know screen game third
down running back i think that's how
he'll be used probably early on but the
other thing that just shows me they were
a little concerned with todd gurley too
is hey let's not forget the detroit
lyons made an offer to malcolm brown the
backup running back for the rams to sign
him in free agency and the rams match
that offer to make sure they got him
back and gave him a signing bonus and
some money guarantee that you usually
don't see a part of backup running back
type deals so that to me is a little bit
of a clue at least that hey they wanted
to have somebody there that knew the
offense is a veteran and been around the
league and knows what it's like to be a
los angeles ram because they're a little
scared of todd gurley but i'm with you
mike this is a big big question all
together hey
one the offensive line was not great the
last seven eight weeks of the year other
than the dallas cowboy game where they
cracked the code of what dallas was
doing on defense their offense aligned
did not dominate people and then out of
the fact that todd gurley was not 100
that does scare me because you know we
forget the rams are kind of a run first
football team they were towards the top
of the league in all rushing statistics
and a lot of their play action passes
and things uh and their passing offense
come off of their ability to run the
ball and that's something i certainly
will evaluate as we get into the season
they do get cooper cup back from a torn
acl assuming he's healthy that will help
the offense because robert woods and
brandon cooks can only do so much
themselves cup had become a very potent
addition and without him the offense was
different so
look
injuries are going to be a factor for
for all teams and you're going to have
to respond and adjust and adapt but that
really did seem to affect that offense
they they seemed to be much more
effective earlier in the year at the end
of the year it just kind of felt like
they were hanging on and to their credit
they got to the super bowl but i think
it was a surprise you know by the middle
of october we just said this team is
destined for the super bowl by
late december into early january there
were real question marks about the rams
and i'm still stunned they came back and
won the game in new orleans and
disrupted the saints patriot super bowl
and i'm i'm more than stunned that they
only scored three points i just wonder
how much
that scars their psyche going into 2019
right the fact that they they put in all
that work all that effort they get to
the super bowl they only score three
points will they have enough faith in
themselves this year to uh you know that
they're going to be around at the end of
the season in a viable position can
climb the mountain and have a better
showing than what they had a year ago
yeah well i it's hard to replicate that
type of intensity you know the to have
the ball bounce your way a few times
whatever it may be it is i mean it's
just the nfl season's long and grueling
and to be able to do it two years in a
row is you know we've seen only the
special teams can do that really but
listen i think the the big thing that
you you talk about that i certainly
question and want to see more of or this
year is is the sean mcvay factor you
know i do feel like teams caught on to
the sean mcvay offense
uh the second half of the year you
talked about how awesome they looked at
the start of the year and all of that
you know i just think again when you're
boy genius and you're one of the best
offensive brains in the game you know
people are going to evaluate a little
bit in the offseason especially the
teams in your division now they've had
two full seasons to play against you and
really get your tendencies we've seen
another a few other teams really give
them issues like the chicago bears where
now teams are gonna steal what they did
a lot some of the coverages the patriots
ran in the super bowl were from that
bearer's game plan uh so i i think that
is the thing i am most excited to see is
sean mcvay reinventing himself and
bringing more to the table on the
offensive side of the ball because as
awesome as he is i did think the offense
lacked a little creativity and some
newness and new plays all together
as we got later into the season
he said it himself at the scouting
combine with a laugh he's now boy
blunder no longer kid genius but this is
just part of the growing pains if you're
going to have a long career in the nfl
you are going to have these moments
where you are tested to try to refine
your approach improve it stay one step
ahead of everybody else that's what so
much of what the game is about as they
catch up to what you're doing you have
to figure out how to stay ahead of it it
gets back to the story you told last
hour when they figure out your audibles
you got to figure out a way to use that
against them right they figure out how
to stop your defense you got to figure
out how to take advantage of the
opportunity that creates at the end of
the day there's still only 11 guys on
the field so if they are aligning and
moving those and those guys and using
them in a way to take away the things
that you want to do there's an opening
somewhere else you just have to learn
how to exploit it and i think that's the
big challenge for the rams and i mean
right out of the gate so i mean they
you go to carolina week one on the road
10 a.m local time game for the rams
that's not going to be easy and they
have the saints come to town the next
week they are going to be ready for even
though the reven i mean what all the
rams did would show up and do their job
they're trying to get to the next game
but the saints are going to have a lot
of pent-up frustration going into that
game it's not going to be an easy start
to the season and if you don't set the
tone right for the rams yeah seahawks
49ers one of those teams may be running
away with the division by the time the
rams figure out what the hell is going
on yeah well you mentioned the first two
games and let's not forget game number
three is going to be the monday night in
cleveland right so that's going to be
scary sunday night on nbc sorry i messed
that up sorry sorry nbc but yeah i mean
you're right they could they could get
off to a slow start and you start off
one and two uh you know that's that's
not easy to climb climb out and get get
back on the positive you know schedule
or a record type of thing but either way
the rams are extremely talented it's
going to be about how they bounce back
from the adversity of losing the super
bowl can they all be focused for another
year around you know are they focused
right now you know it was a short
offseason for them it's their first
short off season so they're not used to
that can you refocus and replicate that
intensity and emotion and attention to
detail for a second year in a row uh
that is really the thing that in my
experience being around one super bowl
team my rookie year that seemed to be
the hard thing to replicate for the 2003
tampa bay buccaneers
yeah uh
it
once you have to go back to zero and
zero and you have the weight of
expectations and like you said you start
at one and two
if that happens how do you dig out of
that it's not easy to do when the
expectations are low hey we're off to a
good start we won one of our out of our
first three when the expectations are
high it feels like the walls are closing
in around
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports